hello the internet welcome to another
episode of challenge Charlie are you
gonna play the theme music or what
really oh okay apparently we don't have
theme music that sucks
now I mean I can do it but it's just
it's not gonna be as good now is it okay
I'm not even talking to anyone I'm so
weird
I have a very special challenge to do
today because I have been challenged by
this man Phillip Schofield who is from
the television the television are the
television just like the Internet but
not as good the Philippine his daughter
Molly have challenged me to do something
called the hoedown throwdown basically
this is a dance routine from Hannah
Montana in the movie a film which I've
most definitely seen and enjoyed and
really this is quite a hard challenge
for me because I am as you might be able
to guess from the internet which means I
I don't exercise at all ever so this is
this is gonna be quite exhausting but
I'm gonna give it my best shots it's
time for the hoedown throwdown
let's go this is my sister she's gonna
be doing the hoedown throwdown with me
that's good
[Music]
it's fine my sister wants me to point
out that she had like half an hour to
learn that dance and it took me like a
day so that's why she was a little bit
behind me but I look like an idiot doing
anyway so whatever I want to say thank
you again to Philip and his daughter
Molly for challenging me to do that it
was a lot of fun and I hope we can be
friends okay bye
that was a rubbish video wasn't it
charlie
yes it was don't ever dance again you
fool